[Music]
thousands of students in the clark
county school district still do not have
the tools they need for distance
education
thank you for joining us tonight at 11
i'm brian loftis
hi there brian and i'm denise valdez but
there are efforts to
ramp up those and get those kids
connected and it's going to take some
leg work
eight news now reporter orco mana
joining us now live with the details
orco well denise and brian to learn from
home
ccst students need access to computers
and the internet
but as of right now there are still
thousands of students in need
but we're told the program known as
connecting kids nevada
and the school district are doing
everything they can
we all know that in this digital world
this was going to be a huge barrier
tammy hanslair is the ceo of communities
in schools which is helping with the
effort known as connecting kids nevada
their website shows ccsd still hasn't
reached nearly 62 thousand students
of those contacted less than 10 percent
need internet or devices but the
situation is
unclear for those not contacted so the
team is community canvassing
we've got people that are passing out
pamphlets in our neighborhoods that we
haven't heard from
we want to be in our grocery stores we
want to be in in the areas that say
give us a call or fill out this survey
individual schools are also taking
action of their own
a lot of my students have devices
brinley middle school teacher jay fair
tells me that's because her principal
has put outreach plans in place
she is 100 percent willing to do
whatever it takes to make sure that our
students
have devices that they have textbooks
they've been making phone calls
she is willing to drive by the houses if
she if she has to
other teachers point to potential
problems even if you have internet
students and teachers are having their
internet use doubled and tripled
a lot of them are going to be out of
data real soon for their internet the
best thing to do
reach out we need to know what you need
so that we can connect you
now it's important to remember that
there is no deadline to ask for this
help
if your student or child needs a
chromebook or internet access contact
the family support center
the number is 1-888-616-2476
and the website is connectingkidsnv.org
reporting live orca mana 8 news now